foreign
I mean we don't have anything everything
we had is gone
I don't I mean I don't really know
I was actually home I was off work
yesterday and uh I was watching you know
keeping up with the weather and
everything and uh we you know we got a
good team locally that stays on top of
it and they started started issuing
mornings for our area and uh so I you
know got out as as they instruct us to
do you know and uh
was making my way to safety you know to
an area that you know was going to be
out of Storms and and uh I didn't make
it 10 minutes down the road and I got a
phone call that that we'd been
completely wiped out so I turned around
and
made my way back to to start assessing
the damage
I just basically gone through stuff to
see what we can find that's salvageable
and
I don't really know from there what
we're going to do
I don't know what our next steps will be
or
anything right now
like I said it just happened in a matter
of minutes and uh coming back and seeing
it the way it is and of course coming up
the road a few homes I got to first you
know I've seen them and and you know
everybody in this area is affected not
just us and it's the whole community and
and it was it was devastating seeing
seeing you know your home like that
seeing other other homes like that and
people you know and everything but you
know it's
we got a good little area around here
and there everybody's pulling together
we we're gonna just take it one step at
a time starting with clean up and then
and then we'll go from there on if we're
gonna you know rebuild or or you know do
something or whatever but
that's all we can do really is just get
get through the processes
what's very revealing it's far worse
than anything I had envisioned or seen
on television
roofs are just gone
and trees looked like toothpicks
and uh there's a lot of work to be done
here
and I know we're going to pull it
together and get this done we've already
applied State resources here
when I get back to Montgomery this
afternoon I'm on
make a call and try to talk to the
president to encourage him to expedite
the state of emergency
[Music]
we just look around at all the folks
that are helping neighbors get things
picked up and patched up just right here
it's just a typical typical of the
values that we Alabama's have that we
just flat helped everybody when we can
when when they need help we want them
everybody wants to help and that's a
good thing right now we need to stay out
of
the way of utility trucks and First
Responders so they can get in and get
their jobs done but there are ways to
volunteer and step up and help if you
want to and you can dial 2-1-1 and
volunteer
you couldn't hear anything and all of a
sudden
that the press in my ear is kind of like
being on the airplane I can feel it and
then I knew the tornado was up on me
and uh you could hear some crashing and
that kind of thing
foreign